over the past few weeks
great big story a Modelo have celebrated
a town that for us represents the best
vision for the future of America a town
that's brought together by a common
spirit of hard work and a shared sense
of community that spirit recently came
under attack three men in Kansas are
facing domestic terrorism charges
federal authorities say the men were
plotting to bomb an apartment complex
and park filled with Somali immigrants
we spent a month living in Garden City
while working on this series the
community welcomed us with open arms and
shared their inspiring stories with us I
don't think people realize how much
energy and effort it takes to hate it's
so much easier and so much less drama
just to be loving and accepting I
believe providing a safe haven for
people is part of being a decent human
being it's how we should treat each
other and I'm glad to see we do that
here Dennis didn't make me like my own
you know I feel like my own I would just
want to live here peaceful making big
change all people from Africa and people
rather sleep here I'm loving the doors
right now and I take that responsibility
because I see people need help I would
love to be unite for everybody
I'm not going lower that's the reason
all of us are here just to to work hard
and help our family not to bring all
these bad things you know it's not like
that our hearts are bigger than theirs
the world can learn a lot about this
little community because if we survive
it here so many years and we stood
together because we understand each
other is not only asked is everybody
great big story a Modelo believe in the
fighting spirit
we stand alongside those who work
together and we celebrate our friends in
Garden City regardless of what color
race country ethnicity that you are
where you've come from we're all here
together Garden City's doing it why
can't the rest of us
you